- Oh my God, who is this? (laughs)
(upbeat music)
- Is he trying to be Indian?
- I'm gonna go with
Indian for this person.
Am I right?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
(bell dings)
- Oh God, it's Ashton Kutcher!
I remember this!
- No! No!
What the (bleep)!
- Looks like he just
rubbed dirt on his face
and put a mustache on
and a really bad wig.
- It's sad because Ashton Kutcher
was totally my celeb crush when I was
in elementary school.
- Never dress up as an Indian again.
- I'm guessing he's supposed to be Chinese
because he's wearing silk robes,
he has a really long mustache.
- So, I'm guessing Chinese.
(bell dings)
- Even if you want to do a loving tribute
to the genre of kung fu, do you really
need to put on this fake mustache?
- He looks more like the rat
that betrayed Harry's
parents in Harry Potter.
- They definitely didn't try.
This is a white guy.
- I don't know who she's supposed to be
'cause she look like a white woman.
- Yeah, there's Emma Stone playing
some white girl in a hat.
- I think they just gave
her some little freckles
and they're like, "Yeah, that's exotic."
- No, I would never
guess that she's supposed
to be part-Asian.
I would assume she's in some
Desperate Housewives show.
- She looks all-white to me.
They didn't even try!
- Don't tell me she's
supposed to be black.
She's not supposed to be
black with this curly hair.
Hispanic, maybe?
- Is she supposed to be
a biracial black woman?
(bell dings)
- Why would they make her Afro-Cuban?
There are too many
Afro-Cubans in the world.
- He looks like Rachel Dolezal.
- The fact that someone like her
goes out of their way, I think,
to aid in humanitarian
causes in other countries
is like, "Yeah, I'll play
an Afro-Cuban woman."
Like, no. That's fucked up.
- You can't train to be a black woman.
Sorry.
I've been training all my life,
and I still struggle with the role.
- You can't just put on some makeup
and some stereotypical clothes
and suddenly embody that culture
in a true and realistic way.
You just can't.
- Because name recognition and box office
success are not valid reasons.
I mean, movies starring people of color,
like Fast 7, they do very well.
- Please stop doing this!
(squeaks)